In this part of our presentation, we're going to be taking a look at ways to optimize our
textures.
The first texture optimization we're going to talk about is making sure that streaming
virtual textures or SVT, which is an alternative system for streaming textures from disk,
is enabled.
In all new Unreal Engine 5.5 projects, SVT is enabled by default, but if you're
in a previous version of Unreal, you can come up here to your project settings, rendering,
then under virtual textures, enable virtual texture support.
Once you've done that, you will need to restart the editor.
Streaming virtual textures work slightly differently than the traditional MIP map based streaming,
in the sense that when Unreal uses the standard MIP based streaming, it has to load the entire
texture for an object, even if a single pixel of that object is visible on screen.
While this method works, it adds unnecessary memory overhead since the full texture data
must be streamed in, regardless of how much of it is actually visible.
Streaming virtual texturing solves this problem by only streaming in parts of a texture
that are needed for what's currently visible.
It does this by dividing all MIP levels into small, fixed-sized tiles.
The GPU then determines exactly which tiles are visible on screen and streams in those
tiles only.
This means that no matter how large the texture is, only the visible tiles are loaded into
memory, which keeps performance and memory usage more consistent.
Again, to start using streaming virtual textures in your project, all you need to do is make
sure that you have virtual texture support enabled, and then restart the editor.
Once that's done, Unreal will automatically handle virtual texture streaming and processing
for your assets.
Now, there are some options that we need to make sure in order to get the best out
of this system, and the first one is the pool config for either fixed pools or transient
pools for your virtual textures.
This section controls how much memory is allocated for virtual textures during runtime.
So again, we've said there's two types of memory pools, there's the fixed pool and
the transient pool.
The fixed pools are serialized settings stored with the project.
These are evaluated from the last to first, and Unreal uses the first configuration that
matches the system setup.
These values persist between editor sessions, meaning they remain consistent every time
the project is open.
Transient pools, on the other hand, are created dynamically at runtime.
They are used by the pool auto-grow system to adjust virtual texture memory as needed.
A virtual texture physical pool will first search these transient configs for a match before
checking the fixed settings.
Transient pools only exist for current editor session, but they can be copied over to the
fixed pool later.
This is a useful way to estimate proper memory pool sizes for a cooked project.
Each pool description inside fixed pools array includes details such as textures, formats,
and tile size.
You can fine tune these settings to match the needs of your project.
For example, you can set virtual texture memory pool to contain DTX1 textures to a
fixed size of 100MB by expanding the pool index and adjusting the size in MB field.
These settings help balance texture quality, streaming, stability, and memory performance
across different hardware targets.
Now when you are working with virtual textures inside of your project, there's a couple
of things that you need to be aware of.
First off, any texture that is brought into Unreal can be used with streaming virtual
textures.
You just need to make sure that it is converted to a virtual texture.
You'll be notified that a texture is a virtual texture, as it will have the little VT on
the side of the texture inside of the content browser.
Once you've imported it, when you're using it inside of a material, you'll want to make
sure that the sampler type is set appropriately.
The available virtual samples are virtual color, virtual grayscale, virtual alpha, normal,
mask, linear color, and virtual linear color grayscale.
Choosing the correct sampler type ensures that Unreal handles the textured data properly
when streaming tiles in and out at runtime.
You can quickly tell whether a texture is a virtual texture or not by clicking on
its thumbnail in the content browser, and you'll see the little VT there.
One of the many techniques Unreal Engine 5 employs in order to help reduce texture
overhead is something called MIP mapping, which is a technique where a texture's resolution
is scaled down into multiple smaller versions of itself.
We can actually see an example of that on our screen right here.
Here's a texture that was imported at 4096 by 4096, and we can see the MIP maps for
it.
Now, Unreal will automatically generate these MIP maps for you if your texture maintains
a power of two ratio in the X and the Y axis.
We'll dive into that a little bit further in our next slide.
But for now, the main thing to understand here is that all we need to do in order
to make sure this optimization takes place is that our texture is imported using this
power of two rule.
Once we have done that, Unreal will automatically do the rest for us.
Now, there are a few options that we have.
You can see here to the right, I have this from a texture group, simple average,
and there's some sharpen and then no MIPs, leave existing MIPs, blur and unfiltered.
What these do is they allow us to adjust the MIP generation so that we can either make
things a little sharper or make them a little blurry.
I very rarely have to adjust these, but in instances such as foliage or maybe something
like a chain link fence or small ornate detail, you might need to run a sharpen just
to get some of that detail back.
Now again, like I said, Unreal will automatically do this MIP generation for us, but your
texture needs to meet certain requirements.
Now, MIP mapping does work for both streamed and virtual textures, but we need to make
sure that our texture is using a power of two in the X and the Y axis.
This could be something like 64 by 64 or 256 by 256, even 512, 1024, 2048, 4096,
and all the way up to 8192.
That's not to say that you can't use non-power of two textures.
We actually have an example of that down here, this imported at 1000 by 1000.
It just means that if you use a texture that is a non-power of two, it is not going
to make use of this MIP map system, and it's always going to be displayed at its
highest resolution, no matter where it's viewed in the world.
Let's just take a little closer look at some of the things we can quickly use to identify
textures that are imported properly.
This here on the left-hand side is taken from the texture viewing tool, which is activated
just by double-clicking on a texture and opening it up.
We can see here imported 1024 by 1024, method streamed, resource size 704, number of MIPs 11.
This number of MIPs in this method stream, this is signifying that this particular texture
right here is set up to be used with the MIP map based texture streaming system.
Next, the exact same texture, we see the same thing imported 1024 by 1024, method virtual streamed,
that's good, resource size 2KB, number of MIPs 11.
So what this means is that this particular texture right here will use the virtual texture
streaming system.
It does have 11 MIP maps and currently occupying only 2KB, and that's because of how the
virtual texture streaming system cuts up textures.
Last but not least, again, this texture imported 1000 by 1000, we see here method not streamed,
resource size 512 by 512, number of MIPs 1.
What this is signifying to us is that this texture right here, no matter how far it's
viewed from the camera or how close, it's always going to occupy this 512 KB of memory.
Now if you're still a little not sure about what MIP maps are actually doing, here's
an example of turning MIP mapping on and off.
We can see here with MIP mapping on, as the texture gets further and further away from
the camera, off into the distance, it's really easy for us to see it kind of making
this pattern, we don't kind of get lost, there isn't this really kind of soupy pattern.
Now with MIP mapping off, what we're doing is we're again taking the exact same texture,
we're not reducing it in any size whatsoever, we are just copying it the exact same
size and the distance, and as you can see, it gets really hard to read the details,
it gets really smushed, it just, it looks like a little bit of just line soup, it is
very very hard to read, so again, we get this really great advantage of using MIP mapping.
Not only is it done for us automatically behind the scenes, but it also helps manage
some visual stuff, making very very distant objects kind of merge together, looking more
natural.
Now the last thing that I want to mention about MIP maps has to do with texture size.
Now, you may be tempted to use the highest resolution texture you possibly can, and
I want you to resist this.
Oftentimes, setting a texture to 4K or 8K means that texture will only actually be
seen when it is very very close to the camera.
In this example, we can see here the MIP mapping texture that was created before, placed on
objects in a world where the camera is positioned kind of far away.
We notice that the 4096 version isn't actually used that much.
What is used a lot though, is the 2048, the 512, 1024, and so on, so we can see that
even though this texture goes all the way up to 4K, that 4K version of the texture
isn't used in a lot of locations.
In fact, most of this scene is comprised of 1024 and lower.
When dealing with alpha channel information inside of Unreal Engine 5, there's two ways
to approach this.
The first way is to use an embedded alpha, which means the alpha information is stored
in the alpha channel of the texture it's related to.
The second way is to do something called a separate alpha.
This is where we take the alpha information and we put it inside of a different texture.
That way, when we bring it into Unreal, we're actually going to have two textures.
We're going to have the base color texture, and then the alpha texture that goes
with that particular base color.
Each method has its own unique advantages and disadvantages.
For example, if we're using an embedded alpha, that's going to give us a texture that's
around 1.3 megabytes.
The reason for this is that any information we put inside the alpha channel, when brought
into Unreal Engine 5, will remain uncompressed.
If we need to have a high resolution alpha for a mask or something like that, by embedding
it into the alpha channel, when we bring that into Unreal Engine 5, we can access the
full resolution of that data.
If we want to store the alpha information inside of a separate texture, what this is
actually going to do is it's going to bring down the size of our base color texture
to about half the size.
So that same 1024 by 1024 texture with the embedded alpha that was 1.33 megabytes will
actually only be around 682 kilobytes of information, or again, about half.
Remember, the reason that it's half is that alpha information stored in the embedded
alpha is uncompressed.
The method that you choose for your project will depend on the needs for your alphas.
I recommend using the separate alpha because it has a couple of workflow advantages that
the embedded alpha does not such as being able to store multiple alpha masks and the
red, green, and blue channels.
The only other piece of advice I have for this is that if you do pick one method, embedded
versus separate, you should continue to use that method throughout the lifetime of
your projects.
Don't mix and match as this can make debugging and finding out which textures are
very large and consuming the most memory much more difficult to come to a proper way
to optimize.
In this example right here, I want to dive a little bit more into the embedded versus
separate alpha so you can understand more why you might choose one versus the other.
But to do this, we're going to go over to the editor and have a look at our two
examples here.
So here we have our embedded and our separate.
Let's grab the embedded and move over to it and then double click on its material so
we can see the texture.
So I'm going to click on this texture right here and let's say that somebody comes
to us and says, hey, we need to reduce the size of all of our foliage textures
from their current size of 512 by 512 down to 256.
So if we come here to our LOD bias and we set this to a value of one, it is going
to bring everything down.
But notice if we do take a look at this, it has reduced the size, but it's also reduced
the visual quality.
So if I was to take this back to zero, you can see here looks like a branch.
Looks like a low resolution branch, right?
Now, if I close this and come over here to our separate alpha, check this out.
I'm going to grab on this, open up the material.
Now I have these two separate textures.
I have the alpha texture and the base color.
Let's go ahead and open up the alpha and it's already set to one.
So let me just undo that so we can have a look at this to begin with.
So this is what it looks like with that set to zero.
Let's bring this down to a value of one and notice pretty much no change, actually.
There is a little bit of change, but overall, things are looking really, really good.
So we've reduced this quite a lot.
And that's really the distinct advantage between these two is that I have now independent
control over reducing the alpha information separately from the base color.
Now, there is one thing that I would like to point out in later versions of Unreal.
If we come over here to this embedded alpha and we open up this, there is a property in
here called Alpha Coverage Thresholds.
And what this will do is this will allow us to adjust the alpha mask intensity so
we can set this to help make the alpha mask more intense as we bring the size of
that texture down to compensate for any loss of detail.
All we need to do is simply input some numbers here.
We don't want to go all the way up to something like one.
We want to keep these numbers between, say, 0.5 and 0.9.
So, you know, just set and see what's right for the textures inside of your project.
In this part of texture optimizations, I'd like to talk about RGB mask packing.
RGB mask packing is a technique used to reduce the number of textures and overall memory footprint
in your project.
It works by storing different grayscale textures in the red, green, blue, and sometimes
alpha channels of a single texture file.
Inside your material, you add the RGB packed texture to the material graph and then pull
from the RGB or A output pins to access the specific data stored in each channel.
This allows you to use one texture for multiple types of information instead of importing
several separate textures.
RGB mask packing is most commonly used for workflows that involve masks or VFX textures
where each channel contains black and white data representing something such as roughness,
metallic, ambient occlusion, or some type of opacity.
When using any type of RGB packed texture, you need to make sure that sRGB is disabled.
This can be accomplished by setting your compression settings on the texture to mask
or by going to texture sRGB and disabling the checkmark box.
The reason this is so important can be seen in the following slide.
On the left, we have sRGB enabled and on the right, we have sRGB disabled.
And at first look, it might be a little bit hard to tell the difference between the
two, but if we zoom in, we can start to see what is actually going on.
First off, on the zoomed in version, if we look at some of these leaves here,
we're actually missing quite a bit of leaf detail.
In fact, we're missing some right here.
We're missing all of this right here.
There's just a lot that is missing.
And if we look with sRGB disabled, notice a lot of that detail is back.
We actually have this entire branch back.
We have just a lot more detail.
We're seeing a lot more information.
And the reason for this is that sRGB is enabling or disabling
gamma correction on your texture.
Since a masked texture is not used to show color information,
but tell the renderer where something should or should not be,
we want to make sure that we are not changing the values inside that texture.
With sRGB disabled, again, the editor is not using that texture
and gamma correcting it, leaving the values at what they are authored at.
And the reason that we want to do this is so that when we use that masked texture,
it shows us exactly the masked information and works in a manner which we are expecting.
In this part of texture optimizations, I'd like to talk about texture compression,
as every texture you import into Unreal Engine 5 is compressed in some way.
Compression helps to reduce the overall memory footprint of your project,
which is especially important for optimizing performance across all platforms.
By default, most textures use either DTX1 or DTX5 compression formats.
DTX1 is used for textures without an alpha channel,
and DTX5 is used for textures that include an alpha channel.
The compression types strike a good balance between visual quality and memory efficiency.
Remember that changing compression settings for a texture will also affect
other related settings automatically.
For example, normal maps use the special compression type that
disables sRGB since gamma correction isn't needed for normal data.
Unreal Engine 5 is also set up in a way that is able to detect the type of texture you're importing.
This means that it will automatically apply the appropriate compression settings
for things like normal maps once they've been imported.
If you ever need a texture to remain completely uncompressed,
you can change the compression setting to user interface or even vector displacement.
However, use this sparingly as uncompressed textures consume much more memory
and can very negatively impact performance,
especially on lower-end or memory-limited platforms.
Making sure that each texture has compression is one of the easiest
and most efficient ways to optimize performance without sacrificing visual quality,
so it's worth understanding how all of these options work.
With each of the compression settings you see here,
you can actively set them and see the results instantly happen inside of the editor.
In this section of texture optimizations, I'd like to talk about texture groups.
Texture groups in Unreal help control how textures are displayed and managed by the GPU.
They determine several important factors that directly impact both performance and visual quality.
Texture groups decide which MIP or LOD resolution will be shown on screen,
and this ensures that textures automatically scale in detail based on distance or performance targets.
Secondly, they help define what type of filtering should be applied when a texture is
minified or magnified by the GPU. In other words, when it's scaled up or down on screen,
how is it going to react? Third, they control how the GPU blends
two MIP levels when you view the surface from a grazing angle.
This helps prevent visual artifacts and ensures smoother transition between MIP levels.
Every texture in your project should be assigned to an appropriate texture group.
These groups are organized by texture type, making it easy to map textures to categories.
For example, normal maps for objects in the environment should use
world normal. Normal maps for characters should use character normal.
Using the right texture group ensures that textures behave exactly as expected,
look correct under different viewing conditions, and perform efficiently on your target platform.